you dare enter this house Monday
September 27 26 to gives a [__] or you
gotta know is you're alive you're
kicking and the world don't know you
dick Oh bono you dick
there you go you bad [__] uncle
Joey coming at you direct and full color
on a Monday except June 26 swingin dick
and giving out [__] fireworks
it's time to find your favorite Chinese
person so you get your fireworks or it's
on the fourth you got no
misunderstandings coming at you like a
[__] savage on kind of Monday I don't
give a [__] no regrets no nothing you're
coming out the box like they [__] all
you a hundred thousand dollars and
you're picking that money up with a
[__] toothpick you understand me
that's how we're rolling today I haven't
seen you guys in a few days I've been
busy I was up in strong island making it
happen if you came to the shows I
appreciate it
anyway let's park this [__] up
and get Monday sparked up on the right
cuz this is Monday's gotta be perfect I
don't [__] around on Mondays you got a
nice breakfast you're right a little bit
you tell your family you love them and
then you go out there like you got
[__] ten guns you don't give a [__]
jack but Joey what's with the [__]
ear beat we sparking or what I'd sparked
this [__] to the other day today
is the anniversary of the day the devil
was buried under the [__] prison you
understand me [__] it let's go for broke
here
[Music]
we talk with smoking two types of repr
today we got this [__] debt oh my god
this [__] death mixing suicide that's
how we're going today I will be taking
it to different levels we got two
podcasts tonight we're breaking huh I
gotta do [__] this we got that [__]
they're doing people to see you
understand me that's number one number
two number [__] - all right I got
jujitsu today I got a little writing I
gotta meet this guy I gotta meet that
guy but before I get to anything before
this day [__] gets put together right
way I gotta hang out with my family
cause that's the most important [__]
day in your life understand me
[Music]
I tell you I love smoking reef with my
family in the [__] morning you
understand me this one gets me ready to
[__] go
everybody wants fans huh I have fans I
want to thank my fans lock you I got no
[__] fans I don't want no [__]
[__] fans and [__] I want family I want
to know that we're [__] together on
this as part of the church like I told
you guys a long time ago you don't need
that you don't need 20 [__] people to
Lingle with you need 3 people when you
could bitch-slap a [__] county you
understand me
as long as everybody's got balls in
heart that's all you did in this [__]
world look at me I'm a [__] [__]
ok with a capital F I got left back in
the seventh grade I got a psychological
problem but you know what they gotta
shoot me in the [__] head to stop me
cuz I don't take no for a [__] answer
I go around the [__] no and that's it
you should be doing I'm not a [__]
human I'm a [__] salesman you're not
an architect you know the doctor you're
a [__] salesman cuz every day you're
selling yourself you gotta sell yourself
to these [__] people and enforce your
marker like Tony an 84 map you got
enforce it man who gives a [__] this is
where you are whether they like it or
[__] it mark this is who the [__] I am
whether you like it or not you don't
like it what are we want me to do what
are y'all gonna do I start by doing the
[__] another head of this pipe Joey
you could be you're driving me crazy
with this discipline with you whether
you smoke mr. Deever
it's time for another Bowl what the [__]
I'm here with my favorite people in the
[__] world trying to put it together
it was Kathy Griffin she's at home
crying to [__] friends the same
[__] idiots that talked her into yeah
it's gonna be brilliant you so valiant
go [__] yourself you want to be valiant
go shoot Isis in the [__] head if
you're not gonna do that you ain't dick
just like me well avenge I'm too old to
be hand-to-hand combat and [__]
around you get the gun there and you're
shooting then you shoot you whatever the
[__] you need to do anyway this one's
for you come suck
I know I got problems for y'all made to
join Scientology and air with those
[__] stupid Gentiles and wait for a
[__] Martian I'm joining the Church
of what's happening now cuz that's the
church I'm from you understand me we
don't give a [__] about what happened
yesterday one high school I was attacked
I don't give a [__] I don't give a [__]
about what happened that we worry about
what's going on today how we're gonna
make it happen today you leave the house
with a [__] knife and a [__] yo-yo
and you come back with 208 law a [__]
blow you could do that then [__]
contact me unless you could do that go
talk to your little [__] friends at
Starbucks and that's that show on
Netflix is it's so interesting I don't
give a [__] you want to stay home and
watch orange is the new purple get the
[__] outta here
you know oranges orange is the color of
my dick the way I come out at night you
understand me Harmons ready to [__]
where do you kill a [__] cuz you
gotta get what's yours everybody's
complaining I'm broke I have this I
don't have that we'll go get it go get
it stop [__] around with your friends
do you really need that I haven't gone
to this concert on seven gives a [__]
why they [__] jumping up and down
you're picking up [__] yard sticks and
that's all that matters you see me jump
I don't jump up I haven't jumped up and
down in [__] 30 years cuz at the end
of the day when you're in the casket who
gives a [__] what gives the [__] is that
you did some with your life you made
something happen and at the end of the
day even if you just got two friends
that's all that [__] matters and
that's it and that's that that's all I
got the other Monday morning
you want to go [__] around with your
friends anyway I'm here I'm queer I'll
be in town all week I think I got the
ice house Thursday night working out
what uncle Joey ten bucks you come down
we've talked I'm gonna go write a few
[__] ideas now and we get there and
then together we put the hour together
you're a part of it I'm a part of it
everybody's [__] happy right
what do you think one more bow what the
[__] what do you do are you gonna do
what are you gonna do one more Bowl you
gotta work [__] sizzle you understand
me there's one of my best listen I could
do podcasts I could do stand-up I came
out with my family's things are like to
do but this hang out with you guys in
the morning
under a [__] tree smoking reefer this
is my all-time favorite you understand
me why because we're together it's
[__] weird how it connected together
by a [__] phone you understand me but
a cool might what am i [__] Einstein
not really I'd smoke another bowl we'll
figure out our own answers
my god this is [__] true madness
I love getting stoned me you gotta
suckers but now I think I pushed the
elbow sometimes you get a little too
strong in Amazon and I'm out of eyes in
and I don't give a [__] anyway I love
you [__] with all my heart you
guys know that without you an update so
thank you for being part of my family
and for letting me be part of your
[__] family and beside that tonight
six o'clock and eight o'clock two
podcasts Thursday night the Ice House
working out with uncle Joey ten bucks
where you gonna get that type of deal we
hang out we smoke a little dope and
you're going to the fourth of July
weekend tip-top Magoo right right or
wrong what the [__] I'm gonna lie to you
most woke up your ass
I love you [__] have a great day
keep your eyes open Isis is everywhere
bring your peace with you and don't let
nobody [__] with you today today's your
lucky today today's the best [__] day
in your life go out there and [__]
give it all you got
and if [__] it doesn't turn out like
that guess what tomorrow's another
[__] then you can let these
[__] know they're gonna suck
your dick uncle Joey here I love you the
Churchill what's happened now
6 & 8 tonight stay black